could we survive without rulers without
the state we have survived for centuries
despite them and they're destructive
wars and stifling oppression crippling
taxes suck half our wealth away
sprinklings just a fraction back it has
been done before archaeology shows some
of our ancestors living in peace for a
few thousand years before armed of
rulers appear on the scene not in caves
but in cities with tens of thousands
enjoying civilization we would recognize
what would life be like without the
state less complicated divisive and
confusing for a start poverty would be
slashed with health our wealth back in
circulation and none wasted on wars and
political spheres enterprise and
innovation flourish without the
regulation that favors large
corporations we do things voluntarily
never because we are threatened with
damage for non-compliance it is a
climate in which our cooperative and
charitable nature can flourish when join
up in a free system we find effective
ways to meet our community's needs we
develop systems in which cream rises to
the top instead of scum
online vendors value their reputations
the states only vital function is
protecting us from other versions of
itself everything else we could do
ourselves we could even develop a less
rigid justice system with no victimless
offenses that benefits from a reduction
in crime and fear we could deter punish
and protect with levels of digital exile
tailored to the offense jails are just
so last century civilization developed
through the connection and cooperation
of people we are more connected now than
at any time in human history we have the
tools to develop structures that self
governed from the bottom up evolving as
times change could we survive a crash of
the global banking system and the
nation-states they under right we could
survive and eventually thrive
you